This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. So there was this moment in my life when I needed to interview the rapper Buster Rhymes for the radio. And this is Friend of the Show, Sean Cole. And so I tried calling his people, which got me pretty much nowhere. So I've been tried googling Buster Rhymes and Boston, which is where I was living at the time because I figured he maybe be coming on tour and I could ambush him backstage or something. And one of the first results I got was a map, like on Google Maps, of a little pond in Trusbury, Massachusetts, which is this little town outside of Boston. And in the pond was this teeny speck of land labeled Buster Rhymes Island. What?
这里是“99%隐形”节目。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在我生活中的某个时期，我需要在电台采访说唱歌手巴斯塔·莱姆斯。这位是节目的老朋友，肖恩·科尔。我试着给他的经纪团队打电话，但几乎毫无进展。于是我开始用谷歌搜索巴斯塔·莱姆斯和波士顿，我当时住在波士顿，我想他可能要来巡演，我可以在后台伏击他或者什么的。我得到的最早结果之一是一张地图，就像谷歌地图那样，显示马萨诸塞州什鲁斯伯里市的一个小池塘，那是波士顿郊外的一个小镇。在池塘里有一个极小的土地斑块，上面标注着“巴斯塔·莱姆斯岛”。什么？
Needless to say, I was a little confused. I mean, you have to understand, like, Shrewsbury is like the least likely, I mean, first of all, for there to be a Buster-Ryme's Island anywhere is pretty unlikely, but Shrewsbury is like this bedroom community for Worcester. It's not even, it's like the most exciting thing to do there on a Saturday night is go to chillies after like, shopping at lumber liquidators. And I was like, is this for real? And then underneath the link for the map
不用说，我当时有点困惑。我的意思是，你得明白，什鲁斯伯里是最不可能的地方，首先，任何地方都不太可能有“巴斯塔·莱姆斯岛”，但什鲁斯伯里是伍斯特的一个卫星城。它甚至不是……周六晚上在那儿最刺激的事大概就是去奇利餐厅，或者在伐木工清仓店购物之后。当时我在想，这是真的吗？然后在这个地图链接的下方
was another link to this short little kind of blurb in the Boston globe with the headline, Buster Rhymes Island is for real. And they interviewed... What did they interview Buster Rhymes? No, they interviewed Buster Rhymes. They interviewed this guy named Kevin O'rian who lives in a house overlooking the pond it's
是另一个链接，指向《波士顿环球报》上的一篇简短报道，标题是：“巴斯塔·莱姆斯岛”是真实的。他们采访了……他们采访了巴斯塔·莱姆斯吗？不，他们没有采访巴斯塔·莱姆斯。他们采访了一个叫凯文·奥赖恩的家伙，他住在一栋俯瞰池塘的房子里，那座池塘
the mill pond is the name of it and who this is still true lists his phone number as the number to call if you want to contact the island so he's the guy who named the island he's the one in the island and this is a quote from the the Globe piece, this guy, Kevin, says, it's a very small little island with rope swinging blueberries
名字叫磨坊池，而且——直到现在依然如此——他把自己的电话号码列为联系该岛的拨打号码，所以他就是那个给岛命名的人，他就在那个岛上。这是《环球报》报道中的原话，凯文这个家伙说，这是一个非常小的小岛，有绳索秋千、蓝莓
and stuff Busta would enjoy. This is adorable. So just to give you a sense of the differences between Busta Rhymes and Buster Rhymes Island. You mean other than the fact that one of them is like an internationally known really fast rapper with 10 albums to his credit, the other one being... Being an island, exactly.
之类的，巴斯塔会喜欢的。这太可爱了。为了让你对巴斯塔·莱姆斯和巴斯塔·莱姆斯岛之间的区别有个概念。你是说除了其中一个是一个国际知名、拥有十张专辑的超快说唱歌手，而另一个是……是个岛，没错。
Being a tiny island. Right, yes. No man is an island after all. It's literally not Buster Rhymes. after uh... missusly no bust around yet but also just sonically um... bustar rinds sounds like this everything in the touch and bustar rinds island sounds like this
是个小岛。对，没错。毕竟人非孤岛。它字面意思上就不是巴斯塔·莱姆斯。在呃……准确地说还没有巴斯塔·莱姆斯，但也从声音上讲，呃……巴斯塔·莱姆斯听起来像这样，触及的一切都这样，而巴斯塔·莱姆斯岛听起来像这样。
so what about this island would you say bespeaks bustarolims? I'd say just pretty much the kind of feel of it. This is Kevin O'Brien. I drove out to Shrewsbury to spend some time with him on the island. It was cold, February. We walked across the ice to get there. Little more about Kevin, he's in his early 30s, works in tech support, and DJ's wedding
那么关于这个岛，你会说有什么地方体现了巴斯塔·莱姆斯的特质呢？我可以说基本上就是那种氛围吧。这是凯文·奥赖恩。我开车去了什鲁斯伯里，和他在岛上待了一会儿。那是寒冷的二月。我们踩着冰走过去。关于凯文的更多信息，他三十岁出头，从事技术支持工作，周末
on the weekends. You know, if you come out here in the summertime, it's in his early 30s, works in tech support, and DJ's wedding on the weekends. You know, if you come out here in the summertime, it's a really nice, relaxing place to be. It's dead silent. It's just really, really low key, and who wouldn't like it? Those aren't aspects of Vester Rhymes, dead silent and low key. He meditates. Kevin started canoeing out to the island about 10 years ago now, when he and his wife first moved here. The pond is practically in their front yard.
还在婚礼上当DJ。你知道，如果你在夏天来这里，（他三十岁出头，从事技术支持工作，周末还在婚礼上当DJ。你知道，如果你在夏天来这里，）这是一个非常美好、放松的地方。死一般的寂静。非常非常低调，谁会不喜欢呢？这些都不是巴斯塔·莱姆斯的特点，死寂和低调。他会冥想。大约十年前，当他和妻子刚搬到这里时，凯文开始划独木舟去那个岛。这个池塘几乎就在他们家前院。
And when you say it's a teeny tiny spike of land, you mean... It's like 40 feet by 40 feet. And there is a rope swing hanging from one of the trees and blueberry bushes, which Kevin planted. He doesn't just visit the island a bunch, he takes care of the island. He cleans up after the teenagers, who leave beer cans lying around, drinks beer himself on the island with his wife and their friends. And when you love a place, the way Kevin loves this place,
当你说是极小的一小块土地时，你的意思是……大概是40英尺乘40英尺。有一根绳索秋千挂在一棵树上，还有凯文种的蓝莓丛。他不仅仅是经常去岛上，他还在照顾这个岛。他清理青少年留在地上的啤酒罐，自己和妻子还有朋友们也在岛上喝啤酒。当你热爱一个地方，像凯文热爱这个地方一样，
you don't want to refer to it generically, that just doesn't feel respectful. So, one day, I was sitting around with my friend Brandon, and we just started talking about how we were always coming over the island and he asked what his name was and it's, oh, It doesn't really have a name. So we started saying, well, how about Buster Rhymes Island? You love Buster Rhymes?
你不会想用泛泛的词来称呼它，那样感觉很不尊重。所以，有一天，我和朋友布兰登坐在一起，我们开始聊起我们总是去那个岛，他问那个岛叫什么名字，结果是，哦，它其实没有名字。所以我们开始说，嗯，叫“巴斯塔·莱姆斯岛”怎么样？你喜欢巴斯塔·莱姆斯吗？
Everybody loves Buster Rhymes and I'm like, all right, you know what? That sounds great because telling somebody the dirty Directions to my house saying, oh, you know, just look up Buster Rhymes Island on Google Maps and follow your way there and I think that sounds a lot better than saying Milpon, so we went we went with Buster Rhymes and we have a lot of respect for him So how did you get it on Google Maps? than saying Milpons, so we won't bust our eyes and we have a lot of respect for him. So how did you get it on Google Maps? We just applied a geotag to it. It's that easy. It's that easy.
每个人都喜欢巴斯塔·莱姆斯，然后我说，好吧，你知道吗？这听起来不错，因为告诉别人怎么去我家的路线时，哦，你知道的，只要在谷歌地图上查一下“巴斯塔·莱姆斯岛”然后顺着走就行了，我觉得这听起来比说“磨坊池”要好得多，所以我们就叫它巴斯塔·莱姆斯岛了，而且我们对他的敬意很深。那么你是怎么把它弄到谷歌地图上的呢？（比说“磨坊池”要好得多，所以我们就叫它巴斯塔·莱姆斯岛了，而且我们对他的敬意很深。那么你是怎么弄到谷歌地图上的呢？）我们只是给它加了个地理标签。就这么简单。就这么简单。
And really, the whole thing would seem like a big joke if it weren't for all the effort Kevin went through to try to make the name stick. Around the time I contacted him, he submitted a formal proposal to the US Board on Geographic Names, which decides what the federal government is going to call a piece of land. He showed me the proposal. Feature class, Island, meaning or significance, Busta Rhymes is a gravel-voiced rapper we all have an incredible amount of respect for. Supporting materials? No, they turned him down. But not for the reasons you might think. The only way you can name the island or a body of land after celebrity is in a
说实话，如果不是凯文为了让这个名字流传下去而付出了那么多努力，整件事看起来就像个大笑话。在我联系他前后，他向美国地名委员会提交了一份正式提案，该委员会负责决定联邦政府如何称呼一块土地。他给我看了那份提案。地物类别：岛屿；含义或意义：巴斯塔·莱姆斯是一位声音沙哑的说唱歌手，我们所有人都对怀有无比的敬意。支持材料？没有，他们拒绝了他。但原因可能和你想的不一样。用名人名字给岛屿或陆地命名的唯一方法是
commemorative fashion. So that person has to be deceased for five years. So unfortunately it really can't be official until a bus to pass is. That could be a long time. I'm willing to wait. So someone has to be dead for five years before the board will consider naming a place after that person what by five years and at the same thing so i called up blue yost who's the executive secretary at the u.s. board on geographic names regarding domestic names names in the united states
通过纪念的方式。因此，那个人必须已经去世五年了。所以不幸的是，在巴斯塔去世之前，它真的无法成为官方名称。那可能要很久。我愿意等。所以一个人必须去世五年后，委员会才会考虑以该人的名字命名一个地方？为什么是五年，同时……于是我给美国地名委员会（负责国内地名，即美国境内的地名）的执行秘书蓝·约斯特打了电话，
for names is another committee anyway when some passes away soon after persons's death, it's an emotional time. And there are close relatives and friends who feel they want to do something to honor this person. And the five year waiting period, this is what's
关于地名，这是另一个委员会。无论如何，当有人去世后不久，那是充满情感的一段时期。会有亲密的朋友和亲属觉得他们想做点什么来纪念这个人。而五年的等待期，这就是
it's said. Do our people disappointed when you tell them about the five year? Yeah. There are people disappointed when you tell them about the five year? Yeah, there are some are disappointed, but after we explain the reasoning, while they're disappointed, they agree, or at least they say they agree with the policy. That it has to be still won a name in Ireland after that person, half a decade later, type of sentimentality. Right.
原因所在。当你们把五年的规定告诉别人时，人们会感到失望吗？是的。当你们把五年的规定告诉别人时，人们会感到失望吗？是的，有些人会失望，但当我们解释了原因后，虽然他们感到失望，但他们表示同意，或者至少他们说他们同意这项政策。即出于某种感伤，哪怕在半个世纪后，依然有人想要用某个人的名字来给岛屿命名。没错。
Lou Yost says the board actually discourages naming places after people at all. It'd rather the name be feature-base. That is, having something to do with the way in Island or Mountain or River looks or sounds or how big it is, rather than who homesteaded there. But with the exploration of the West and Alaska, it was bound to happen. Oh, so these guys have been around a long time. Oh, the board's been around since 1890. Wow. And then he told me that six days after JFK was shot,
蓝·约斯特说，委员会实际上根本不鼓励以人的名字来命名地方。它更倾向于以地物特征来命名。也就是说，名字要与岛屿、山脉或河流的外观、声音或大小有关，而不是看谁在那里开垦了宅地。但随着对西部和阿拉斯加的探索，这种情况不可避免地发生了。哦，所以这些家伙已经存在很长时间了。哦，委员会自1890年以来就存在了。哇。然后他告诉我，在肯尼迪总统遇刺六天后，
so 1963, Lyndon Johnson announced that Cape Canaveral would be renamed Cape Kennedy to commemorate the president, who's Jackie Kennedy's idea. Well, people in Florida did not like that at all. Why not? Oh, I mean, it had been called Cape Canaveral for like 400 years. And I didn't know this,
也就是1963年，林登·约翰逊宣布卡纳维拉尔角将更名为肯尼迪角，以纪念这位总统，这是杰奎琳·肯尼迪的主意。嗯，佛罗里达州的人们对此非常不满。为什么不呢？哦，我的意思是，它被称为卡纳维拉尔角已经有大约400年了。我当时并不知道，
Canaveral is a Spanish word. Canaveral. It roughly means a plantation of canes or reeds. Canaveral. Anyhow, 10 years later, the Florida legislature voted to change the name back from Cape Kennedy to Cape Canaveral, and the board went along with it. And it was this event that led to the one-year waiting period.
卡纳维拉尔是一个西班牙语单词。Canaveral。它大致意思是甘蔗或芦苇种植园。Canaveral。无论如何，十年后，佛罗里达州立法机构投票决定将名字从肯尼迪角改回卡纳维拉尔角，委员会也顺从了这一决定。正是这一事件催生了一年的等待期。
But I thought it was a five-year waiting period. It was one year then, and it changed to five years in 1995. Gotcha. And there has never, never! Been an exception to the rule since then. No naming places after people who have been dead less than five years, and certainly no naming a place after someone who's still alive. If the board starts naming features for living people and then they go on and do something
但我以为那是五年的等待期呢。当时是一年，后来在1995年改成了五年。明白了。从那以后，从来没有！从来没有过例外。禁止以去世不到五年的死者名字命名地方，更不用说以仍然在世的人的名字命名地方了。如果委员会开始以在世之人的名字命名地物，然后他们又去做出什么
heinous, that's what I look good. Buster Rhymes is being accused of using gays slurs at a fast food restaurant in Miami. This was at Cheeseburger Baby in Miami Beach and he was apparently there for some promotional purposes and it's a 24 hour restaurant. He went there late at night with his posse and there was a very very long line. And I'm looking, oh there it is. But as I was learning about all of this, I remembered this one place that had been named after someone, not while he was living, but not that long after he'd died either. And here we are, in Central Square in Cambridge.
滔天大罪，那我的面子可不好看。巴斯塔·莱姆斯被指控在迈阿密的一家快餐店使用针对同性恋的侮辱性词汇。这发生在迈阿密海滩的“芝士汉堡宝贝”餐厅，他显然是为了某种宣传目的而去那里的，那是一家24小时营业的餐厅。他深夜带着他的一帮随从去了那里，当时排着非常非常长的队。我正在找，哦，就在那儿。但当我了解到所有这些事情时，我想起了一个地方，它确实以某个人的名字命名了，不是在他生前，但也不是在他死后很久。现在我们到了，在剑桥的中央广场。
Cambridge, Massachusetts, where I was born. There's a black sign in the sidewalk that says, Mark Sandman Square, the corner of Brookline Street and Mass Ave. Mark Sandman's another musician. He was the lead singer of the band Morphine. He died in 1999, just collapsed on stage during a concert in Italy. And then just one year later, this sign went up on this corner. Right outside the Middle East. The Middle East nightclub where Sandman used to perform or just hang out.
马萨诸塞州剑桥市，我出生的地方。人行道上有一个黑色的牌子，上面写着“马克·桑德曼广场”，位于布鲁克莱恩街和麻省大道交界处。马克·桑德曼是另一位音乐人。他是“吗啡”乐队的主唱。他在1999年去世，在意大利的一场音乐会上在舞台上突然晕倒。仅仅一年后，这个标志就竖在了这个街角。就在中东酒吧外面。桑德曼过去常常在那里表演或闲逛的中东夜总会。
The sign was Joseph Sader's idea. He was one of the owners of the Middle East. Do you remember the dedication ceremony? I think the public work called us and they said the sign is ready. So I wanted to put the sign up, put the flowers and bunch of friends and we had little party in his flowers and bunch of friends and you know, and we had little party, you know, and his memory and thinking over the good time. So, how was Joseph able to dedicate the corner to Mark Sandman only one year after he died when the regulations says that he has to wait at least five years?
这个招牌是约瑟夫·萨德的主意。他是中东酒吧的老板之一。你还记得落成仪式吗？我想公共工程部门给我们打电话说牌子准备好了。所以我想要把牌子挂起来，放上花朵和一群朋友，我们举办了一个小派对，（放上花朵和一群朋友，你知道，然后我们举办了一个小派对，你知道，）为了纪念他，也为了回想那些美好的时光。那么，为什么约瑟夫能在马克·桑德曼去世仅一年后就将街角献给他，而规章制度规定必须至少等待五年呢？
From the way you're explaining it, it would have been relegated to the city of Cambridge. This is Lou Yost again at the US Board on geographic names. A square or a city park or building would be what we consider an administrative feature. The board has relegated that authority to name those features to the local administrative agencies. So if we were in the city, we would be up to the city, what they wanted to name the park. Nonetheless, I explained the five-year rule to Joseph at the Middle East and how, especially in that first year, of course, everybody wants to name something
按照你的解释，这应该被归给剑桥市管辖。这是美国地名委员会的蓝·约斯特再次发言。广场、城市公园或建筑会被我们视为行政地物。委员会已将命名这些地物的权力下放给当地的行政机构。所以如果我们在这个城市，那就取决于城市，看他们想把公园命名为什么。尽管如此，我还是向中东酒吧的约瑟夫解释了五年规则，以及为什么尤其是在第一年，当然每个人都想用
after their loved one who died. Everybody want to stop on the wagon. They want to name everything after him. They want to name everything after him. No, I understand. It wasn't like this was my, you know, I mean, definitely you'll miss him. He moved on.
他们去世的亲人的名字来命名某样东西。每个人都想赶上这班车。他们想用他的名字命名一切。他们想用他的名字命名一切。不，我明白。这不像是我的，你知道我的意思，当然你会想念他。他已经离去了。
We get cheated by not having him around, but it wasn't emotional. It's, you know, I mean, it's. It wasn he moved on. We get cheated by not having him around, but it wasn't emotional, it's, you know, I mean, it's... It wasn't an emotional thing, you see? No, not at all. It was like it's true, you know, friend around, you know. They did a lot in this community every time you call on him
我们因失去他而感到吃亏，但这并不是出于情感。这是，你知道，我的意思是……这并不是出于情感，你明白吗？不，一点也不。这就像是真的，你知道的，周围有个朋友，你知道的。他在这个社区做了很多事，每次你找他
for fundraising or a show, you know, he dared to play for free or barely any money, so. Definitely, he did the due diligence socially, you know? What would he think of the sign, do you think of the squirre? Affatas, he would. No, Mark, he would laugh, you know, but it doesn't matter. I also got in touch with the mayor's office in Cambridge to ask what the criteria are for naming a corner of the city after someone. They sent me the application you fill out when you want one of those signs hammered into the sidewalk.
筹款或演出，你知道的，他都敢免费演出或者只拿一点点钱，所以。毫无疑问，他在社会层面上尽到了应尽的责任，对吧？你觉得他对这个招牌、对这个广场会有什么看法？老实说，他会笑的。不，马克，他会笑的，你知道，但没关系。我还联系了剑桥市长办公室，询问以某人的名字命名城市街角的标准是什么。他们给我发了申请表，当你想要把其中一块牌子钉进人行道时，你就得填这张表。
Mark Sandman would have fit under the category, distinguished careers by present or former residents who have achieved state or national fame. And then I asked them if the person in question had to be deceased and they didn't respond, but on the application it says, deceased it's in with a question mark, and then a box to check. So that makes it sound like you can memorialize people
马克·桑德曼符合“现任或前任居民取得州或国家声誉的杰出职业”这一类别。然后我问他们相关人员是否必须已经去世，他们没有回复，但在申请表上写着“已去世”，后面带有一个问号，然后是一个复选框。所以这听起来好像你也可以纪念
who are still alive. Or it's just like a test, because they just remove all the ones that are still alive. Or they automatically kick those out. Exactly. Or something. But then I started noticing those black commemorative signs everywhere, all around Cambridge.
仍然在世的人。或者这就像是个测试，因为他们会直接删掉所有仍然在世的人。或者他们会自动把那些人踢出去。Exactly。或者诸如此类。但随后我开始注意到这些黑色的纪念牌到处都是，整个剑桥到处都是。
There's John T. Johnny Collins Square, Commander Francis X Buddy Foster Square, Robert E. Goodman Road. It's been very loose. This is Charlie Sullivan with the Cambridge Historical Commission. Anyone who is interested in having a square named after a family member, like there's one of those signs right on the corner. Helen and John Black Square.
有约翰·T·强尼·柯林斯广场、弗朗西斯·X·巴迪·福斯特司令广场、罗伯特·E·古德曼路。一直以来都很宽松。这是剑桥历史委员会的查理·沙利文。任何有兴趣以家庭成员的名字命名广场的人，比如其中一块牌子就在拐角处。海伦和约翰·布拉克广场。
Could just ask a city counselor and they would put in a council order and the city would do it. So we have intersections in some parts of town that have one of those signs on each of the four corners. Really? Yeah. The preponderance of... Dedications. The preponderance, yeah. Proliferation of dedications.
只需要求助一位市议员，他们就会提交一份议会提案，市政府就会照办。所以在我们城镇的一些地方，十字路口的四个拐角上各有一个这样的牌子。真的吗？是的。这种压倒性的……纪念活动。压倒性的，是的。纪念活动的激增。
You seem... you seem not so pleased with that. Well, it gets to be a little bit of a clutter after a while and they begin to lose their meaning. So, I think the... See, Council is a little more resistant than they used to be. They're running out of places to put these signs. So just to be clear, these places they're not recognized by the US board of geographic names. Right. So they're not on federal maps or used by the federal government in any way. But that said, local usage is something the board takes into account when it's evaluating a proposal.
你似乎……你似乎对此不太高兴。嗯，一段时间后这会变得有点杂乱，它们开始失去意义。所以，我认为……看，市议会比过去更有抵触情绪了。他们快没有地方放这些牌子了。所以需要明确的是，这些地方并没有得到美国地名委员会的承认。没错。所以它们没有出现在联邦地图上，也没有被联邦政府以任何方式使用。话虽如此，但在评估提案时，本地使用情况是委员会会考虑的一个因素。
And not just the local authority recognizing the name, but... The locals, like those folks up there in that house over Yonder. Exactly. This is Kevin O'Brien again. That Buster Rhymes Island. We would basically have to go to them and say, hey, do you know the name of that island? And if they were to say, oh, that's Buster Rhymes Island or whatever else we're going to name it, then that would be considered local usage. So if if local folks know what to call it and everybody calls it that, then you have a lot more, a lot more weight going to the government and saying, I'd like to name this island this. But as far as Kevin knows, nobody except for him and his wife and their friends
不仅是地方当局承认这个名字，还有……当地人，就像那边那栋房子里的那些家伙。Exactly。这是凯文·奥赖恩再次发言。那个巴斯塔·莱姆斯岛。我们基本上得去问他们，嘿，你知道那个岛叫什么名字吗？如果他们说，哦，那是巴斯塔·莱姆斯岛，或者我们要给它起别的什么名字，那么这就会被视为当地用法。所以如果当地人知道该怎么叫它，每个人都这么叫，那么你在向政府提出“我想把这个岛命名为这个”时，就会有更大的分量。但据凯文所知，除了他和他的妻子以及他们的朋友，没有人
call this island anything. We spent about an hour on the island together. As I say it was very cold and just as we were about to leave these two kids who'd been skating out in the middle of the pond came wandering over. Two boys, maybe 10 years old. Good morning. Good morning. What you doing? Doing a radio story about this island. Do you know anything about this island? No. I just moved here. Oh, did you? Well, if you look up this island on Google Maps, you know what it's called?
把这个岛叫作别的什么。我们在岛上一起待了大约一个小时。正如我所说，天气非常冷，正当我们准备离开时，两个在池塘中间滑冰的孩子闲逛过来了。两个男孩，大概10岁左右。早上好。早上好。你们在干嘛？正在做一个关于这个岛的广播故事。你们知道这个岛的任何事吗？不知道。我刚搬到这里。哦，是吗？嗯，如果你在谷歌地图上查这个岛，你知道它叫什么吗？
No. It's called Buster Rhymes Island. Buster Rhymes? Do you know who that is? Nope. He's a rapper. Why would this be named after him? He named it after him. I named it after him. Because he's a rapper. Why would this be named after him? He named it after him.
不知道。它叫巴斯塔·莱姆斯岛。巴斯塔·莱姆斯？你知道那是谁吗？不知道。他是个说唱歌手。为什么这个地方要以他的名字命名？他用他的名字给它命名。我用他的名字给它命名。因为他是个说唱歌手。为什么这个地方要以他的名字命名？他用他的名字给它命名。
He named it after him. Because he's a big fan. Because I'm a big fan, yeah. What would you name this island if you could name it something? Um, I don't know. Wait, wait, the shoe is very island, I guess. The shoe is very island? Yeah.
他用他的名字给它命名。因为我是个大粉丝。因为我是个大粉丝，对。如果你能给这个岛起个名字，你会叫它什么？嗯，我不知道。等等，鞋子非常岛屿，我想。鞋子非常岛屿？对。
Do you have a favorite musician or anything like that? Uh, no. No. I don't either. Do you have a favorite musician or anything like that? Uh, no. I don't need it. Feel free to come with the Buster-I'm Island anytime though. Good to meet you guys. This is what we teach you. Local usage, right?
你们有什么最喜欢的音乐人或者类似的人吗？呃，没有。没有。我也没有。你们有什么最喜欢的音乐人或者类似的人吗？呃，没有。我不需要。不过随时欢迎你们来巴斯塔·莱姆斯岛。很高兴认识你们。这就是我们教给你们的。当地用法，对吧？
You get that's right. We just witnessed Buster-I'm Island being used. That's right. That's right. I did. We just conned them into it. Exactly. Exactly. Just condom into it. I should say I did try contacting Buster Rhymes again told his managers all about the island that I wanted to interview on.
你懂的，没错。我们刚刚见证了巴斯塔·莱姆斯岛被使用。没错。没错。我确实见证了。我们把他们给忽悠进去了。Exactly。Exactly。就是把他们忽悠进去了。我得说我确实再次尝试联系巴斯塔·莱姆斯，把这个岛以及我想采访他的事全告诉了他的经纪人们。
And again, they never responded. Also, a few days after I first emailed them, I went back on Google Maps and the geotag was gone. I contacted Kevin right away, it was the first he'd heard of it, and he said, well I know what I have to do. Add it again and see how long it takes to be taken down again. Sure enough, a couple weeks later, Busta Rhymes Island was back on the map, like Mount Rainier appearing and disappearing with the weather. And not long after that, friend of mine randomly met Busta in a bar in New York. She was dating a guy who knew him.
然而他们依然没有回复。而且，在我第一次给他们发邮件几天后，我再次登录谷歌地图，发现地理标签不见了。我马上联系了凯文，这也是他第一次听说这事，他说，好吧，我知道我该怎么做了。再添加一次，看看这次需要多久才会再次被撤下。果不其然，几个星期后，“巴斯塔·莱姆斯岛”又回到了地图上，就像雷尼尔山一样随着天气时隐时现。不久之后，我的一个朋友在纽约的一个酒吧里偶然遇到了巴斯塔。她在和一个认识他的人约会。
And when she asked him about the island, Busta said, this is a quote, yeah, I heard about that. Yeah, I heard about that. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Sean Cole, with Sam Greenspan, Katie Mangle, Avery, Troubleman, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco, and produce of the offices of ArcSside, a brilliant architecture firm that we love rubbing elbows with every single day in beautiful downtown Oakland, California.
当她问起关于这个岛的事时，巴斯塔说，这是原话，对，我听说过这事。对，我听说过这事。“99%隐形”本周由肖恩·科尔制作，合作者有萨姆·格林斯潘、凯蒂·明格尔、艾弗里、特鲁布曼以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW的项目，并在ArcSside的办公室制作节目，ArcSside是一家出色的建筑事务所，我们每天在加州美丽的奥克兰市中心都与他们紧密合作。
You can find the show and like the show on Facebook, I tweet at Roman Mars, Sam tweets at Sam listens, every tweets at truffleman, Katie Mingle sometimes tweets at Katie Mingle. We also have this really great Tumblr that Avery takes care of, which is the law because she's the youngest. But if you would, do as a kindness, until everyone you know to subscribe to the show at 99pion.org. Radio Topee from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞本节目，我在推特上是@RomanMars，萨姆是@Samlistens，艾弗里是@truffleman，凯蒂·明格尔有时是@KatieMingle。我们还有一个由艾弗里负责打理的非常棒的Tumblr，因为她是年纪最小的所以这是她的职责。如果你愿意的话，请帮个忙，告诉你知道的所有人在99pion.org上订阅本节目。PRX广播转播。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。